hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt ich
backe heute eine crêpe torte mit lemon
curt füllung und zwar habe ich diese
torte in frankreich gebacken das habt
ihr auch neulich in meinem sell your
video gesehen und da haben mich dann
viele nach diesem rezept gefragt heute
ist es soweit und zwar ist es eine torte
die besteht aus kreft dann habe ich die
lebensführung mit drin und obendrauf ist
noch diese pc schicht die wir dann auch
noch flambiert und wir werden jetzt
zusammen erst mal die crêpes herstellen
und dafür zeige ich euch prinzip hut
hatten
für den teig brauche ich 500 gramm mehl
2 esslöffel zucker einen halben
teelöffel das 6 1 500 milliliter milch
und 500 milliliter mineralwasser mit
kohlensäure und 100 gramm zerlassene
butter zuerst nehme ich jetzt das mehl
und füllt es in eine rührschüssel und
für diesen tag brauche jetzt eine
küchenmaschine das geht alles mit einem
kochlöffel bzw
in bagdad nämlich ein loch in der mitte
und jetzt verteidigt es mails ein
bisschen bis zum schüssel rand da gebe
ich jetzt auch zucker und salz mit
trends und da kommen die eier mit rein
und jetzt muss ich zuerst mal die eier
mit dem mehl verrühren und zwar fand ihr
da jetzt auch in der mitte an und rührt
dann immer wieder dass mehr von außen
mit dazu und zu bekommen wir das ganze
sein körbchen frei
und sobald ihr merkt dass es etwas
schwieriger wird mit dem rühren
gebt ihr im schluck milch mit dazu wenn
man nämlich zuerst weniger flüssigkeit
mit dabei hat dann wird das mehl nicht
klumpp ich jetzt einfach so lange rühren
bis das komplette mail verriet
die
wenn sich mehl und milch verbunden haben
kommt jetzt auch noch das wasser mit
dazu
und wenn sich jetzt die zutaten
verbunden haben kommt jetzt zum schluss
noch die butter mit rein
die gibt es natürlich noch den tollen
geschmack und der teig muss jetzt erst
mal ruhen und in der zwischenzeit kann
ich schon mal das level curt vorbereiten
da hatte ich euch ja bereits gezeigt in
einem video bei diesem rezept ist es
jetzt nur so dass wir mehr butter
benutzen aber ich bereite zuerst mal
slamka zu und dann geht es gleich weiter
ich streiche das jetzt hier durch damit
die körbchen einfach weggehen und danach
werde ich es gleich mit frischhaltefolie
abdecken und das lenkrad muss dann erst
mal auf zimmertemperatur kommen bevor
die butter mit rein kommt und dieses mal
habe ich jetzt mehr butter mit dabei als
bei meinem normalen lemon card rezept
und zwar deswegen weil es dann so wie
eine art buttercreme wird damit die
dieses land hat eben auch festwirt und
während es jedoch noch auf
zimmertemperatur abgekühlt kann ich in
der zwischenzeit schon mal dick laut
auspacken
der teig dorf jetzt ausruhen und das
level könnt ist jetzt immer noch warm
also laura und jetzt muss ich hier noch
ein bisschen vanille extrakt so für uns
hatte ich vorhin vergessen einfach für
den geschmack das rühre ich hier noch
kurz ein und habe jetzt auch bereits
schon eine pfanne erhitzt und bei crêpes
und bei pfannkuchen ist es wird der erst
da wird meistens nichts aber das finde
ich gar nicht schlimm denn kaum hat an
dem ich immer schön probieren durch die
butter habe ich direkt im teig so ein
paar kleine klümpchen mit drin
und deswegen spreche ich den teig einmal
kurz durch und sieht dann sind die
nämlich auch mit weg
und ich habe hier ein bisschen öl also
dass jetzt eine geschmacksneutrale
sonnenblumenöl und bei den ersten mache
ich das immer so dass da ein bisschen öl
in die pfanne kommt und wenn es etwas zu
viel war kann man es auch mit bisschen
druck wegnehmen so und jetzt kommt der
teig direkt in die heiße pfanne wenn ihr
direkt hoch nimmt und gleich schwenkt
hat man am ende einen schönen dingen
crêpes und dann lese ich den grip immer
erst am rand und dann kann man ihnen die
wende beim ersten treff ist es meist so
dass dennoch nicht so schön wird und ab
dem zweiten werden zu schöner da weiß
man wie hoch man die hitze stellen muss
und wie viel capt reinkommt
das hört sich jetzt hier auf ein
abrupter denn wir müssen ja gleich kalt
sein
und jetzt mache ich einfach alle aus und
kann dann gleicht die creme noch fertig
machen
die fertigen lasse ich hier übrigens auf
abkühlen gittern abkühlen aber nicht
übereinander gestapelt sondern erst mal
einzeln und sobald sie kalt sind kann
ich sie übereinander stapeln und so
lagern bis wir gleich die torte
zusammensetzen damit sie einfach so ganz
schnell kalt werden
die crêpes sind jetzt alle ausgebacken
und abgekühlt und jetzt muss ich die
torte vorbereiten und zwar nehme ich dir
jetzt dafür dann nämlich immer mehrere
aufeinander und habe jetzt hier einen
bug rahmen mit 16 zentimeter durchmesser
ihr könnt aber zum beispiel auch einen
teller oder einen anderen runden
gegenstand nehmen und könnten jetzt als
schneide vorlage benutzen und das
drumrum schneiden
und die reste die wir haben die kann man
entweder direkt vernaschen
man kann sie zum beispiel aber auch in
super mit rein geben so eine flädlesuppe
aber ich habe zwei esslöffel zucker mit
dabei da finde ich schon fast zu süß
deswegen am besten gleich vernaschen
oder zum beispiel den kameramännern
geben
bitteschön
als nächstes kann ich jetzt die weiche
butter nehmen und jetzt die butter lemon
körpercreme zu bereiten
und zwar wird die einmal kurz
aufgeschlagen und sobald die butter dann
weiß cremig ist kann ich es löffelweise
das leben könnte dazu geben
jetzt haben wir eine schöne tortenplatte
jetzt kommt der erste clip drauf
natürlich könnt ihr den durchmesser auch
etwas größer machen habt ihr weniger
reste aber wir zwei finden reste sogar
richtig gut aber so ist die torte eben
höher also sogar höher stapeln genau
jetzt nimmt die samira die creme jetzt
kannst du schön drauf streichen
und jetzt wird einfach immer creme und
kalt wird es einfach geschichtet
vielleicht mache ich das da unten drin
ganz kurz und du kannst dann den rest
machen wir da unten drin geht ein
bisschen schwieriger
jetzt kommt der letzte crêpes obendrauf
und jetzt muss die torte erst mal für
etwa eine stunde in den kühlschrank und
anschließend kommt dann noch die pc
schicht obendrauf
die torte ist jetzt abgekühlt ich hatte
sie im kühlschrank auch abgedeckt und
jetzt wollen wir noch die meerenge masse
machen und zwar brauchen wir dafür nur
drei zutaten dass es zum einen dreimal
eiweiß 150 gramm zucker und eine prise
salz und da gibt es verschiedene
möglichkeiten um diese masse
herzustellen und zwar muss das eiweiß
erhitzt werden damit zum beispiel auf
die salmonellen getötet werden wenn
eventuell wenn die paten sind aber eben
auch damit die masse später stabil ist
ich werde jetzt dieses mal in der
kenwood machen ich habe in meinem video
mit den high end marshmallow muffin habe
ich die möglichkeit gezeigt wo man das
eiweiß mit dem zucker in einem wasserbad
erhitzt und dann aufschlägt und dann
gibt eben noch die möglichkeit dass man
den zuckersirup aufkauft und das dann
damit dazu gibt so wie bei der mutter
krebs zum beispiel die auch schon mal
gemacht hatte genau wir machen das hier
drin geben jetzt das eiklar hier rein
jetzt kann der zucker direkt mit dazu
gesundheit und eine prise salz und jetzt
werde ich die masse auf 80 grad erhitzen
und zwar so etwa für fünf minuten und
wenn es die temperatur erreicht hat
werde ich dann aufschlagen
also jetzt erstmal nur langsam rühren
und hier kann ich ja die temperatur
kontrollieren und so bald fünf minuten
auf 80 grad war beides schlagen
jetzt nach fünf minuten kann ich die
temperatur wegnehmen und das eiweiß
steif schlagen und da muss es einfach
kalt gerührt werden dann ist richtig
stabil
die pc masse ist jetzt wieder abgekühlt
also werden sie wieder kalt geschlagen
und jetzt ist ja auch schön stabil
jetzt will ich sie in einen spritzbeutel
mit einer großen loch thüle und an der
stelle können natürlich auch ohne
spritzbeutel arbeiten und diese creme
einfach mit einem löffel zum beispiel
auf der torte anbringen kann man auch
schön dekorieren
jetzt kann ich die gräben direkt auf die
torte spritzen
ich mache jetzt solche tupfer drauf
und jetzt sieht die torte sondern euch
auch schon hübsch aus aber damit die
oberfläche dieser bc masse auch ein
bisschen trocknet und genau richtig
hübsch aussieht flambieren mir das ganze
jetzt nochmal weil es den teil weg
lassen möchte kann zum beispiel auch das
so lassen wir haben das eiweiß erhitzt
so ist es allerdings noch etwas feucht
und ich möchte dass die oberfläche ein
bisschen karamellisiert wer es ganz
weglassen möchte kann auch zum beispiel
einfach puderzucker darüber geben aber
das fertige langweilige story and butter
zucker
ich geb dir gleich bruder super
da geht jetzt immer mit dem slum biehrer
drum
immer kurz mit prinz ist schlimm als sie
dürfen nicht zu nah an die torte aber
eben nah genug damit eben brown wird
jetzt ist die torte fertig und wird
können sie am schneiden und diese
schwarzen stellen da oben das sehen
übrigens die röstaromen eine torte mit
reizdarm wunden dies nicht angefangen
das gehört zu mir habe ich zugleich
probieren verschmerzen lassen wir jetzt
heute am besten den marius probieren und
zwei ster marius macht der der macht
eigentlich immer unsere fotos und steht
auch hinter der kamera und heute darf er
probieren also ich find optisch sie die
torte natürlich super aus denn wir haben
diese ganz vielen einzelnen schichten
die aus krepp und dem lehmann körper
stehen und die das leveln karte sah er
seitlich und schmeckt auch wirklich sehr
sauer in dieser torte aber dadurch dass
wir diese bc schicht oben drauf haben
wird es eben noch mal schön ausgeglichen
und das bringt eben die süße mit rein
darf steht jetzt probieren
also damals war in frankreich nicht mit
dabei ist dir eigentlich zum ersten mal
heute und ich finde theater braucht sehr
gut
und falls ihr das rezept nach machen
wollt dann geht auf meinem blog aus selb
- blog.de da stets noch mal ganz genau
und die samira davids ihre restlichen
crêpes auf essen wir haben noch ganz
viele reste und ja ich finds optisch
eine sehr hübsche torte und
geschmacklich natürlich auch druck
also viel spaß beim nachbacken und bis
zum nächsten mal
ja wir machen mit waffeln
stocker war führte apfel hoffen
ich mache eine crêpe torte ja deswegen
habe ich das für dich weg gelegt dazu
wir drehen eigentlich ist okay wenn
jetzt alle einlaufen
das atom moratorium